the turbonomic sustainable it dashboard
IBM Cloud for VMware as a service and
IBM's recognition in the G2 winter
reports all on this episode of IBM Tech
now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
to get the ball rolling today let's talk
a little about sustainability in it
sustainability initiatives are becoming
more important than ever for Enterprises
and while 86 percent of Enterprise
organizations have a sustainability
strategy only 35 percent have acted on
that plan
organizations say the biggest challenge
to enacting these strategies and
achieving sustainability goals is not
having the right tools and experience
and that's why we're thrilled to
announce the new sustainable it
dashboard for IBM turbonomic application
resource management which allows you to
embed sustainability into your daily
operations
the sustainable it dashboard provides
easy visibility into Data Center power
and energy consumption and its estimated
carbon impact
it also allows you to execute resourcing
actions that reduce energy use and
carbon emissions even projecting the
energy and Emissions impact of taking
certain turbonomic actions
these new turbonomic capabilities can
further facilitate your company's
sustainability initiatives by connecting
and feeding data to the IBM and visi ESG
Suite this will give you insight into
how it decisions intersect with your
sustainability goals and Reporting
to learn more about turbonomics new
sustainable it dashboard check out the
link I've got in the description of this
video
next up let's take a look at IBM Cloud
for VMware as a service organizations
are increasingly turning to the cloud to
modernize their infrastructure and
applications for VMware workloads if
this is you it's likely that you're not
only seeking security speed and scale
you also want to expedite time to value
and lower the complexity and risk of
migrating and modernizing Mission
critical workloads to the cloud
IBM Cloud for VMware as a service is a
new offering that combines IBM's hybrid
Cloud strategy with VMware capabilities
simply put it is a secured operated and
managed service to help you deploy a
faster path to modernization and
accelerate your adoption of hybrid cloud
some of the benefits include High
availability your selection of bare
metal configurations elastic deployments
and a single Tenon instance that you
won't have to share with other customers
to learn more about VMware as a service
hit the link below
and finally to wrap up our final Tech
now episode of 2022 I'd like to offer a
huge congratulations to all the IBM
offerings that were recognized in the G2
winter reports all told IBM offerings
were featured in over 1200 unique
reports earning over 180 leadership
awards across multiple categories
IBM products and solutions were ranked
number one in 120 reports including IBM
API connect mq IBM RPA Watson assistant
and a whole host of others we also
ranked in the top three in an additional
258 reports these reports rank the
world's best software based on authentic
timely reviews from real users breaking
down the latest market trends in
technology and software so a big thank
you to all of you who contributed your
feedback
for more info on the G2 winter reports
see the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now this is our
last episode of 2022 but we'll be back
in 2023 to bring you more news
announcements and information
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics I've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video and again please don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to
stay up to date on what's going on in
Tech now